welcome to the Mana Recaps this is you
season 4. at the end of season three our
anti-hero the stalker Joe Goldberg is
following his latest Obsession Marianne
to Paris but it's actually in London
where he finally finds her and it's not
the Romantic reunion he was hoping for
because you know she's afraid he's gonna
murder her but Joe's like whoa I'm a
good guy I would never hurt you and to
prove it to her and himself Joe actually
lets Marianne go so Joe decides to stick
around London for the season with a new
Alias Jonathan Moore and a new look the
bearded sexy Professor with his love of
literature Joe makes a great professor
and he's doing better not stalking this
season through the window he sees his
co-worker's girlfriend Kate Galvin the
you talk starts up but he shuts it down
real quick Joe's doing better now but by
chance one night Joe saves Kate from a
mugging and Joe finds himself in the
Inner Circle of London's young ultra
wealthy social Elite who are selfish and
vapid and Joe hates them except for
their one friend Ruiz Montrose a real
good guy who grew up poor has a lot in
common with Joe these two hit it off but
the rest of the group are very hard
Partiers Joe can't keep up he blacks out
he wakes up with a bad hangover and a
dead Malcolm on his table Joe assumes he
killed him for being a douche and sets
about disposing the body but that night
Joe gets mysterious text turns out
someone was trying to frame Joe and is
now very intrigued by Joe's professional
Body Disposal skills and so this season
the you of Jose inter monologue is this
mysterious killer and it's a murder
mystery as Joe tries to figure out which
of these socialites did the deed murder
mystery is not Joe's favorite genre so
he gets help from a star student Nadia
who tells him to have his detective lean
into their strengths so Joe puts his
stalker skills to use finds out to
everyone's dirty secrets and turns out
they all had some motive to kill Malcolm
but when another one's murdered the
artist Simon seems someone's targeting
this whole group and is dubbed the Eat
the Rich killer now for some reason this
whole group has very quickly taken to
their new friend Jonathan except for the
one Joe actually likes Kate she's very
standoffish and is justifiably in a bad
mood because her boyfriend was just
murdered but soon she and Joe connect
over past trauma and startup a torrid
Affair so with the killer hunting them
the group hides at lady Phoebe's country
house for the weekend where they have a
murder mystery party which is maybe in
bad taste and this tends to happen in
this situation there's a real murder and
this time the killer tries to frame Kate
Joe helps Kate dispose of the body but
he's caught by their other friend rolled
rolled hates Joe because he's obsessed
with Kate and is jealous that these two
are falling in love of so he puts Joe on
trial as they eat the rich killer and
sentences him to being hunted in the
woods but Joe saved by the real killer
Rhys Montrose yes turns out Rhys kind of
hates all his spoiled friends and he's
gonna run for mayor can't have their
dirty secrets infecting his campaign he
wants Joe to help him frame rolled for
the murders but chose a good guy and
frees him instead with Reese running
from Air he's always protected Joe can't
just kill him but Reese breaks into
Joe's Apartment all the time he still
wants Joe to be his best friend which in
this case means finding someone to frame
or else he's going to frame Joe
conveniently Phoebe is abducted by her
stalker so Joe gets there first and plan
some evidence she goes down as the
Etheridge killer with that taken care of
Reese backs off a bit Joe and Kate
continue to date soon he meets her
father Tom Lockwood a very powerful
billionaire Kate hates him because he's
the evil kind who you know poisons Water
Supplies to give kids cancer when Kate's
not around he reveals that he knows
Joe's real identity and is sure that he
killed his wife love Quinn now long
story short resend Lockwood both want
Joe to kill the other form recess
leverage because he's found Marianne and
taken her hostage but Lockwood's like yo
I know where Reese isolated so Joe
finally gets the upper hand on the
killer Reese Montrose he interrogates
him for Marion's location but Reese is
playing dumb I don't even know who that
is Joe gets angry loses control and
kills him but now something really weird
happens because Rhys Montrose steps Out
of the Shadows wait what's happening is
this a frame job with an identical twin
turns out it's just that classic twist
this series Montrose was he in Joe's
head Joe has been stalking someone this
season the realeries Montrose he became
obsessed not in a romantic way but as a
best friend and Joe's mind created him
as an alternate personality one who
takes over and kills people so congrats
Joe you finally had a complete mental
break and that's why you've been so good
this season you sectioned off your dark
side into fake grease unfortunately this
means Joe did not let Marianne go she's
locked in the cage he's like I'm so
sorry it really wasn't me Joe's gonna
let her go then flee the country but
before he can she overdoses from the
pills his Reese Persona gave her and Joe
feels terrible that once again he's
killed someone he loved speaking of love
things with Kate are going great and Joe
finally starts addressing her in his
head as you but she's got problems with
her evil dad who's still trying to
control her life and turns out it wasn't
him who killed the kids with cancer it
was her when she was working for him so
Joe steps in with his white knight
instincts teams up with his Dark Side to
kill her evil father and while Joe
thinks Kate could be the one he knows
he's got to say goodbye he has a dream
with all the use from his past to help
him see Joe you're the problem there's
only one way to break the cycle and so
in an emotional breakthrough Joe accepts
he has this dark side but he makes the
choice to end it by jumping off the
bridge and killing himself but the
bridge wasn't high enough Joe's totally
fine Kate's like yo what the hell bro
he's like Kate I'm sorry but I'm a bad
person she points out though that if you
feel bad about being bad how bad can you
be huh I never thought about it like
that before she's like look I got a dark
side too but we both want to be good so
let's work together and keep each other
good but before he begins his new good
life there's a loose end with his
student Nadia who threw a series of
events has come to suspect him earlier
she found Marianne in the basement but
for absolutely nonsense reasons they
decided they couldn't call the cops so
instead they switched the pills and
Marianne faked her death yeah she's
totally fine made it back to France with
her daughter but now Nadia finds
evidence to take Joe down unfortunately
Joe is one step ahead but he's like whoa
I'm a good person now I'm not gonna kill
you I will however kill your boyfriend
and frame you for it uh so you're
welcome and now Joe Goldberg's ready to
start fresh which unfortunately involves
shaving his beard with his girlfriend
Kate's billionaire Powers he's able to
undo his fake death and come back with
his real name he's come to accept his
Dark Passenger as part of himself but
with Keitel he thinks he can control it
and be good and so Joe Goldberg is
living his dream back in New York with a
loving girlfriend he can be a full-time
supportive boyfriend too and now with
billions of dollars backing him he's
completely gotten away with all of his
crimes and that's where you season 4
comes to an end
if you liked this recap hit that
subscribe button for more of the best
Recaps of TV and movies
[Music]